Resident Evil seven has been heralded as
a return to form a classic
uncompromising fright fest and indeed it
is in place of pandering blockbuster
action the game delivers intimate horror
with a highly focused scope and all the
trappings you'd expect from a survival
game no superfluous skill trees or
meaningless fetch quests just the
stomach churning tension of guiding a
relatively helpless character out of a
waking nightmare every time you start to
feel powerful enough to kick some ass
the game finds a way to pull the rug out
from under and while the setting and
characters have no obvious connections
to any previous Resident Evil games the
series DNA can be felt in everything
from the puzzles and keys to the subtle
psychological tricks used to cultivate
dread you're about to see some more but
rv7 clearly takes cues from modern
horror games as well most notably by
opting for a first-person perspective
outlast fans may recognize a lot of
structural similarities in large
portions of the campaign which outside
of some optional backtracking to collect
items follows a linear and highly
scripted series of events annoyingly
that sometimes means wasting ammo on
enemies who are not supposed to die
until later fights but at least those
moments reinforce the tense oppressive
atmosphere that persists from start to
finish the experience does start to drag
a bit by the end though as you end up
performing similar tasks throughout the
game but make no mistake there are
memorable moments and when they hit they
hit hard
despite its clarity of vision including
restraint in its pursuit of that vision
re7 still takes a few bold chances to
refresh the campaign and renew the
horror as you progress
where do you think you're going some of
these chances stem from its story which
follows average guy ethan winters into a
dilapidated manor deep in the Louisiana
bayou though ethan searching for his
missing wife the narrative never
devolves into trite damsel in distress
cliches over all the narrative delivers
the twists are generally predictable but
it's exciting to see them unfold and the
game never lingers on a reveal for too
long the setting helps as well every
mouldy floorboard every flickering light
every losing end trail feels unbearably
the textures details and sounds are
without exception utterly gross in the
best way and impressively re7 relies far
more on its atmosphere than cheap jump
scares
[Applause]
re7 also smartly uses each family member
to different effect the father Jack
provides in-your-face terror the mother
Marguerite demands a stealthier approach
and the son Lucas sets elaborate
saw-like traps that keep you off balance
and make you wary of things you once
took for granted these different
approaches add welcome variety in a way
that feels completely natural in the
context of the world enhancing your
immersion while mixing up the gameplay
outside of the family
collectible VHS tapes add even more
variety each one contains a playable
flashback from a different characters
perspective which works beautifully as
both a narrative device and a way to
break up Ethan's exhausting mission
you'll also encounter puzzles though
unlike early Resident Evil games these
play only a minor role overall and most
are simple and easy to solve there are
of course a few things that go bump in
the night as well and for those
occasions Ethan has access to a small
but diverse collection of weapons the
game contains more guns than I expected
but I never felt super powered not even
close even the final chapter mainly
relies on horror and tension by and
large re7 keeps it simple
prioritizing tone over action and in
true survival horror fashion everything
is in short supply you'll definitely
need to manage your limited inventory
and carefully scour areas for essential
items unfortunately I found most generic
enemies to be a little less capable than
I would have liked if they catch you off
guard or confront you in a bottleneck
they can be tough to put down but I
could frequently see them coming and
they're neither fast nor smart enough to
catch you when you simply run the other
direction knowing when to run away is
arguably part of any horror game but I
still would have preferred something
more threatening especially since I was
playing on the highest difficulty
available out of the box boss fights
were also a bit of a mix one thrilling
battle recaptures the classic resident
evil boss designed by throwing you in a
creepy intricate arena but another more
action-oriented fight forced me to win
in a specific way that wasn't
immediately
clearly thankfully the games generally
pretty generous when you die responding
you nearby with all your ammo and
healing items intact also if you own a
PS VR system this game does everything
it can to deliver a top tier experience
including a robust set of options
designed to minimize discomfort while I
can't imagine playing the entire 12 hour
campaign with a headset on re7 is
undoubtedly an amazing option for VR
fans by the end of the campaign I was
ready for the game to be over but that's
okay re7 ends just as it starts the odd
States welcome and after the fact I felt
like I'd survived a truly harrowing
journey the boss fights maybe slightly
inconsistent and certain sections might
drag after a while but re7
executes its overall vision with
impressive patience and precision by
returning to horror Resident Evil has
once again become something special
[Music]